hi guys I'm Eric Voss and Marvel just
released a brand new teaser for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 now the
director James Gunn has hinted that
another longer trailer is coming soon a
B with the release of dr. strange but
this short teaser definitely has a ton
of huge details hidden in it something
that's really easy to miss but also a
pretty sure stuff that tells us a lot
about this movie so you know screw it
let's break the stuff down okay so right
off the bat we get the return of blue
Suede's hooked on a feeling and I love
this like opening fake out sound effect
where we hear what sounds like maybe a
gun being loaded but no it's just Peter
Quinn's cassette tape being loaded into
the cassette player and these opening
images are all like super dramatic with
these brief glimpses of Drax as the
camera peeks around the corner then
Gamora as she walks out of frame but the
music increases in volume and it's clear
that this guardians of the galaxy sequel
is gonna have that same loose fun tone
at the first movie did but here's my
question where is this place what are we
looking at these round tunnels kind of
look like the tunnels on the Millennium
Falcon's so I'm thinking this is like
some kind of ship and then we also see
this sign saying space suits for
emergencies and for fun I think that
maybe onboard the Milano while these
tunnels might not be in the same
location they might not be on a ship at
all
they could be underground but hold that
thought let's move on
okay so we get this amazing shot of
star-lord at the end of a tunnel looking
through this circular portal and I think
this tunnel might be the same tone that
we stopped beginning at the trailer and
why I think star-lord could be
underground here you look in the
background of the shot that looks like
it's part of some massive cavern also
notice how the music here says now I
have a theory that I'm working on that I
think there could be a reason why we
hear this lyric sync up with this image
in particular but I'll come back to it
it'll make a lot more sense later on we
also get these shots of Gamora looking
like a total badass and let's break down
these shots frame by frame first if you
look closely Gamora is stepping on a
large fleshy type surface and there are
all these tentacles in the shot and this
is probably a bolus it's a
multi-dimensional being that appeared in
the concept art that James Gunn tweeted
out rumor has it it's going to be a
beast that the guardians have to fight
early on in the movie but also this
location looks super interesting there's
this big golden orb and all the shiny
architecture and a lot of people
comparing this surreal look to the
universal Church of truth from the DNA
run of the guardians of the galaxy
comics and I won't go too into it but
the reason it's interesting is that in
those comics there's a character named
Adam warlock who is associated with the
soul gem and the soul gem aka the soul
stone in the MCU is one of the two
remaining Infinity stones out there and
a lot of people think that this movie is
gonna be where the soul stone appears to
set up for Thanos and the Avengers
affinity wars movies so I don't know how
much of the universal Church of truth
trichter truth is going to be in this
movie but it could be how the guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 works the soul stone
into the MCU okay moving on
okay I have no idea what's going on here
with rocket and yondu but it is clunkers
apparently the other Raptors have turned
on yondu bringing them to the guardians
of the galaxy and I love the idea that
these two mercenaries are teaming up on
their own awesome side mission whatever
it ends up being also there's a rumor
going around that it's raining men it
has been added to the soundtrack of this
movie and if so I couldn't think of a
better song choice for what we're seeing
right now except maybe let the bodies
hit the floor
[Music]
I don't know you be the judge also if
you look closely you can see yonder
whistling in the shot and his Yakka
arrow is barely visible slicing through
these guys as they're falling now in the
comics
yondu controls the arrow with the pin on
his head which glows and a lot of people
thought that now that the pin is back on
his head in its full form we might see
that on screen but I'm actually glad
that they're keeping the whistling which
I thought was a really cool thing they
added to the character in the first
movie it's just like a fun folksy way to
summon a deadly weapon and then we get
nebula who's Gamora sister a fellow
adopted daughter of Thanos we last saw
her in the first movie fighting Gamora
severing her own arm and escaping in AZ
and our ship and now it looks like she's
in some sort of captivity
now based on to her positioning in the
poster released for the movie it seems
like she might be on the guardians of
galaxies side this time which makes me
think we may be in store for another
amazing prison escape scene I know the
perfect guys for the job we also get
this cool shot of Peter quill here and
by the looks of the background this is
the same location that we saw Gamora
fighting the appleís and I just love how
carefree and don't give up star-lord is
here like whatever
another stupid giant tentacle monster we
gotta take care of let's do this and
before I move on I just love this shot
of the Raptors getting blown to hell by
this interesting blue pulse now check
out those trees on the sides of the
frame here I have a theory about where
this is taking place that I will get to
right after we look at this next section
there are two types of beings in the
universe
those who've danced and those who do not
now earlier we saw skylord piloting the
Milano in a frenzy and now it looks like
he's crash-landed on this interesting
forest planet which I think might be the
same planet he goes deep down inside up
in that other shot we saw and we now see
the reverse of it here okay now time for
that theory that I have been blue
balling me with this whole video one
thing missing from this trailer is one
of the big mysteries from the first
guardians of the galaxy Peter Quill's
father who is now in this movie can be
played by Kurt Russell but here's the
thing about that I'm thinking we are
seeing him in this trailer
because quills father is named ego the
Living Planet he is an ancient super
being who just took human form when he
came to earth in this planet that quill
is stuck on I think that is his dad
that's why I think the Ravagers are
getting lit up in that other shot
they've come to this planet chasing
after star-lord and now pop a planet is
swatting the crap out of them like lay
off more Sun also maybe I shouldn't even
bring this up but if this planet is ego
it makes it a little creepy when you
listen to that song lyric again as we
saw oil in the tunnel come on gross man
that's your dad
hey moving on I guess yes sir Corey is
not you just need to find a woman who is
pathetic like you thanks buddy do you
need a hug no no I do not
now this banter between quill and Drax
is just great it sets up this guardians
of the galaxy to have even more of that
rom-com tension with Gamora and the
thing I want to point out here is look
at quills sweatshirt now when you take a
look at the concept art from the
keyboard from the prison scene of the
first Guardians you get kind of an
alphabet that you can use to decode the
letters on quills sweatshirt and it
translates to gears shift now that could
mean anything maybe just in the general
sense that the guardians are shifting
gears for the second movie not sure let
me know what you think it means in the
comments now let's go to this final shot
here
this is just awesome rocket does this
no-look shot through the wall and if you
look closely at those screens in the
background it seems like there's some
kind of chaos going on maybe a prison
riot which makes me think this is part
of that possible Prison Break scene I
was theorizing before and then rocket is
smiling because he knows that this gun
can blow holes and walls and then of
course my favorite part of this trailer
everyone saw this baby Groot on Rockets
shoulder and it's an awesome reversal of
rocket on Groot shoulder in the first
movie he's even got his own little
star-lord jacket ah jeez they're gonna
sell so freakin many of those toys okay
that's it for now again there will be
another guardians of the galaxy vol 2
trailer coming out very soon and may
even be out by the time you're watching
this video so keep your eye out for our
breakdown of that I'm so excited for
this movie and this second movie looks
like it's gonna have the same sense of
humor and pure fun so I'm excited to see
what James Gunn in the whole cast has in
store for us for this one so if you
liked this video please hit like and
subscribe to new rockstars so you can
see all of our videos and of course
share it with your friends you can also
contribute to us on patreon a big thanks
to all of our current patrons you guys
are great you're our favorite don't tell
anyone else you can follow me on twitter
at EA boss with any theories or
questions or predictions that you have
you can also follow a new rock stars on
Twitter at new rockstars for info on
when our future videos are gonna be
coming out okay thanks bye
[Music]